The California sea lion.
Yes!
Oh, hi everybody.
My name is Leo, I am a junior ranger.
And this is my puppy, Hero.
Look Hero, I'm gonna score.
One, two, three!
Oops, almost.
Oh, you found my basketball.
Wow, you're really good.
Bravo!
This animal looks like the sea lions I've seen at the zoo performing tricks.
You know what we should do?
Let's take a photo and send it to my sister, Katie.
She is also a junior ranger.
Hi Katie, so what did you find?
Hi Leo, you were right.
The animal you found is a sea lion.
And this one is a California sea lion.
California sea lions are intelligent, have good memories, and learn fast.
That's why they are often taught to perform tricks at zoos.
Someone must have taught the sea lion to juggle balls.
California sea lions can do a lot more than that.
They're so clever, that the United States Navy uses them in missions.
California sea lions have been taught by the Navy...
...to perform tasks like picking up underwater objects.
That's so cool!